[Musique]
c'est le premier petit matin gelé au
domaine devant l'entrée achille 2 par le
fils est au lit son border collie
commencent leur journée d'éleveurs
de bonheur et de bonne humeur
avec des météo comme ça ça se passe bien
fait un petit tour de contrôle
la droite doucement
là on est dans une prairie qui sert
normalement de parking aussi lors des
événements donc ça ça remplace la
tondeuse et je remplace la tondeuse dans
d'autres entreprises et dans d'autres
communes
karachi et ses troupeaux de solognote
reconnaissables à leur tête couleur
châtaigne fonde l'écopâturage c'est la
race locale et en plus elles sont
autonomes moi ça me permet de faire
autre chose et c'est un produit de
qualité c'est une race qui est très
rustique les moutons c'est tout ce que
le visiteur peut voir en ce moment le
château est fermée entre est interdite
[Musique]
pendant les trois mois et demi divers la
famille se retrouve au calme seul sur 27
hectares la vie de château prochain
achille rejoint véronique sa mère quand
la saison touristique se met en pause
celle des petits et des grands travaux
commencent à villesavin
l'ars le père est à l'orangerie il
soigne ses petits protégés celui-ci à
200 en
c-1 quatre saisons on s'aperçoit qu'il a
des petits fruits l'année fleuve qui est
là des oranje qui sont rasées ça c'est
des oranges avec pour faire de la
marmelade
l'été c'est la salle de réception pour
les mariages l'hiver elle retrouve sa
vocation première à ses succulents m
citronniers orangers et autres
mandariniers à l'abri du froid
autrefois c'était systématique on les
rentrées le 15 octobre pour lire sortir
le 15 mai et maintenant on est plutôt
vers le 15 novembre
pour être fière quelquefois fin mars et
voilà il ya une différence de deux mois
sur dix ans
et quand les feuilles commencent à
tomber les projets d'avenir fleurissent
dans la tête des châtelains
[Musique]
j'ai dans l'idée
d'intégrer un joli jardin dans tout cet
espace là oui à l'origine c'était le
potager du château et puis dans
l'ancienne demeure du secrétaire des
finances de françois 1er ils y allaient
très gros chantiers à lancer depuis
qu'ils sont propriétaires le couple a
réussi à refaire petit à petit presque
tous les toits leur contribution à
l'histoire de france la superficie et là
c'est à peu près dix mille mètres carrés
de toiture oui c'est beaucoup un hectare
en principe on utilise ce terme pour les
pour les champs
d'ordinaire chaque année d'ouverture au
public permet de restaurer un morceau de
château avec le co vide les travaux ont
pris deux ans de retard l'idée c'était
de faire au moins une lucarne pour pas
passé une année à vide et finalement on
s'est dit on trouvera bien les
financements en fait la partie toi qui
reste à faire les quatre lucarne le
campanile la loggia le perron
voilà total de la facture au moins cinq
cent mille euros pendant ce temps les
menus travaux continuent dans un vent
glacial l'art c'est achille au moins des
gars avec les bananiers géant qu'avec
les agrumes
à l'heure de la pause rendez-vous à la
rôtisserie françois 1er est là la
famille de ce parent se réchauffe un peu
ça fait du bien
comme je suis né un on habitait cette
pièce là c'est à dire qu'il y avait une
grande table au milieu et c'était ce qui
servait de cuisine à ma mère et c'était
une autre pièce à vivre avant vraiment
avant que ce soit totalement ouvert à la
visite quand on a les visiteurs on n'en
profite pas et puis on court tout le
temps et là on se pose et puis oui si on
a la chance d'avoir des belles journées
on passe du temps dehors s'il fait s'il
fait moins beau on fait ce qu'il a à
faire à l'intérieur mais on ne le fait
plus doucement et on en profite c'est
vrai
et la liste des choses à faire est
longue changer un éclairage ou encore
cirer les parcs et des pièces qui se
visite
l etat pas encombrer la sombre du roi
les touristes reviendront avec le
printemps ainsi va la vie de château au
21ème siècle